this is the top 10 fastest checkmates I
hope you're ready for it let's get right
into it this first one is number 10 The
Budapest smothered mate you've probably
seen it before if you haven't here we go
D4 Knight F6 C4 and then E5 it's just
saying go ahead take my Pawn on E5 I'm
giving it to you right and of course
this comes with complications so D takes
E5 happens many people take the pawn
Knight to G4 moving the Knight out of
danger also attacking the E5 Pawn at the
same time right white says I want to
keep the pawn that I just captured from
you that you gave me for free so Knight
to F3 Knight F3 defends the POG we need
to attack this Pawn again or else we are
going to get kicked away so Knight to C6
we're attacking the pawn once again
saying please give me the pawn back and
I'll have some development at the same
time white says not today I'm going to
keep this Pawn because you gave it to me
and it's for free so Bishop 2f4 now
we're defending it twice when it's
attacked twice and we're taking first so
we're gonna lose a piece there that's
not gonna work out so while back goes
with Bishop to B4 check which is a very
nice move developing each of pieces out
you need to do this in every single game
white says I need to defend right if we
go Knight C3 okay we have a damage of
the structure double pawns the two sets
of double pawns that's not the most fun
thing ever right then if we go with the
bishop back to D2 then E5 will be
hanging if Knight back to D2 then again
E5 will be hanging and if Queen to D2
we're just going to take the queen so
Queen D2 is not really a good move at
all in fact Knight B to D2 is the move
that they choose Katie the knight in the
bishop in the same squares to defend the
pawn here right and we still as black
here have to figure out how do we win
this Pawn black says easy Queen E7 we go
right here we're going to attack this
Pawn right here now we're attacking it
three different times only defended by
two pieces we're gonna win this Pawn so
white says okay nothing I can really do
about it well at least give me the
bishop pair with A3 Pawn to A3 and this
right here is where the magic happens
you're like what is Checkmate where how
can you checkmate with all these pieces
around the king well we about to show
you right now the move here spectacular
pause the video if you need to but of
course it's black to move here it is
live plays
nutty takes G5 while Knight G takes E5
that is a big boy move from a big fella
it doesn't look like it makes any sense
though right I'm just taking a pawn when
my Bishop is attacked what since does
that even make well let's see what
happens after a takes B4 hopefully you
can find the move pause the video what
is the move
[Music]
black to move the Checkmate is
three smothered here we go with number
nine this one is called the England
Gambit mate now very similar to The
Budapest Gambit let's see what it is
after D4 E5 that we see a lot in the
Budapest Gambit but white still saying
hey you're gonna give me the pawn I'm
gonna take it so it captures the pawn he
takes E5 boom thank you very much for
that now black says hey I need to get my
Pawn back so we put the queen on E7 this
time instead of Knight to C6 right well
enough it's very strange because the
Queen's in front of the bishop and we
saw in the Budapest Gambit that the
bishop comes out to beat fourth to check
after clean E7 attacks the pawn Knight
F3 defends the pot we need to attack it
again or else what are we doing Knight
to C6 right so we attack this spawn not
once but twice now and white does that
we've seen in the Budapest Gambit as
well and just simple things defending
the Pod the pawn wants to and needs to
be defended right so we defended with
Bishop to F4 now here comes the trick
after Bishop two F4 we go Queen B4 check
triple attack not only the king's Under
Fire in check the bishop is attacked and
B2 is under a fire as well under attack
so white goes with you know what hey I'm
not going to take my Bishop if I go C3
or move the Knight you're going to just
take the bishop right Queen blocking is
going to run into some tricks with Queen
B2 and Bishop over to B4 very scary
stuff so hey oh it should be two I'm
totally fine with this I'll back up
right you're not going to take the spawn
you're gonna hit the queen and now that
the queen is attacked Queen takes B2
attacks The Rook here now we have the
move that we wanted to play it's right
here which is Bishop to C3 Bishop C3 is
now saying hey I'm going to attack your
queen and defend my Rook at the same
time question mark moved because it is a
question mark move it is in trouble
right now white is after Bishop to C3
Bishop to B4 great move here I didn't
have to move my queen best defenses
offense so we actually attacked this
bishop while defending our Queen you
can't take it because we'll take the
king immediately it's pinned can't do
anything about it so white says all
right cool Queen D2 I have everything
under control right now says white at
least they think so after we make this
move right here Bishop to C3 ends it on
the spot how is that possible if Knight
takes C3 decisive material you can hit
the button resign that is Queen takes A1
and you are done right that's going to
be checked we're going to lose you want
to lose some decisive material it's game
over so that's why we put the clean on
D2 says white so Queen takes C3 it's a
double question mark why because it's
mate black to move what do you do the
move here is Queen to C1 and he's not
mate England Gambit trap another one we
got him okay coming in at number eight
we have the Owens defense Fool's mate
pattern let's check this one out this
one's a cool one right here we start
with E4 and then B6 very strange but of
course it's very playable so the Owens
defense sometimes you see it in the
French as well next move d4 take the
whole Center if they give it to you
Bishop B7 and Bishop D3 I'd like playing
against the oldest defense this way as
well this trap is very fun and it can
happen to your opponent today F5 after
the F5 move looks crazy but of course it
has actually some Merit to it after Pawn
takes F5 he takes F5 Bishop takes G2
boom haha gotcha tricha except we
tricked you Queen H5 and we live that's
a big move check okay cool that's
awesome but I can defend it right G6
says black oh when you take or do
anything I'm gonna take the Rook I'm
gonna be up some decisive material
falling into the Trap F takes G6 boom
right okay we can take this we're
threatening G7 we're threatening both of
these our Checkmate by the way very cool
Checkmate except if I go Knight F6 haha
double question mark But it actually is
hitting the queen has some nice Merit
here if I go G7 hey you can take the
queen wow that's kind of annoying if I
move the queen again I'm gonna take this
Rook but white has an outstanding move
and that move is
GTX 87 oh my goodness the man has left
the building wait what my Queen's
hanging take it Knight takes H5 thank
you appreciate it I'm sure you can spot
the move now it never got around to
taking his Rook on H1 because he's done
after this move right here Bishop G6 is
mate this is the Owens defense fools May
pattern coming in at number seven we
have the Italian game smothered mate or
aka the Blackbird chilling Gambit it
actually comes from that now here it is
this is for black after E4 E5 writes
standard stuff Knight F3 Knight to C6
you see this all the time so many times
I'm sure you even played this today
Knight to C6 Bishop to C4 developing
Italian game play it game Etc stuff like
that but it it's very very loud after a
move like Knight to D4 you've never seen
this one what is this your opponent is
already tricked I have no idea why is he
moving the Knight twice and giving up
his E5 Fawn I'm just gonna take it
Knight takes E5 falling right into the
Trap Queen G5 and we live we hit the
knight in G2 at this same time but
wife's like wait what it's just what are
you doing Knight takes F7 anyway what
I'm forking the queen in The Rook now
you see the double question mark there
but as a human what is this look I'm
forking I should be winning on the spot
right black says hold on a minute Queen
takes G2 I'm gonna attack this Rook it's
also a double attack right and we're
attacking E4 white says you know what
move the Rook defend it it's fine
nothing's wrong guess what I still have
a rook in the back here right but it's
black to move in fact he's already lost
white that is when he takes E4 check
wait I can just block this right block
with the queen oh no no we're not gonna
do that come on this is a family channel
but Bishop to E2 that should be fine but
remember the name of this the Italian
game smothered mate well you already
know what the movie is I see you looking
at it right now it's black to move what
do you do the move is
938 it's smothered get him off the board
here we are with number six this one is
the Cairo Khan smothered maid a very
common one it can happen in your games
literally today let's see what this is
E4 C6 a Carol Converse solid opening
right we always usually go D4 in these
moves you got lots of uh lots of moves
you can make but D4 is is the usual move
in this position after D5 after the D5
move white goes Knight to C3 D takes E4
we say we're gonna take back so we take
it back Knight takes E4 Knight to D7 the
goal here is to develop so we can
capture back with the Knights white
girls Queen to E2 right strange move
what is with these strange Queen moves
here well let's see what happens after
Queen E2 Knight F6 following the plan
double question mark following the plan
like we just said we wanted to do is put
this Knight on F6 but it's a wrap on the
spot why to move what do you do here it
is
Knight D6 simple
smothered mates with a little bit of
gravy a little bit of smothered and some
gravy there and here we are with number
five this one is from a bird's opening
in fact it's a Fool's made pattern from
the birds opening let's check and see
what that is F4 the bird pretty
unorthodox here you don't see this a lot
but if you do you can actually try this
trick literally today after F4 E5 you're
like what is up with the pawn sacrifices
as you start seeing these gamuts and
these cool things and these Pawn
sacrifices just seem to work with the
Right Moves behind it after E5 okay
we're giving up a pawn white says I will
happily take that one what are you gonna
do queen E7 or Knight C6 this isn't a
Budapest or England Gambit but in fact
we're gonna play D6 off for another pop
here have another pod after D6 he takes
D6 white says cool I'll take it I'm up a
pawn thank you appreciate it and then
Bishop takes the D6 here so white says
all right cool you know what got the
pawn I'm feeling good let's just develop
a piece knight to C3 double question
mark get him off the board black to move
here what do you do
here it is the move here is Queen H4 for
the score oh man that hurts this is a
check though what do you mean so after
G3 we block it now you have two ways to
do this and the most spectacular way is
well of course the saying goes when you
can sack your queen you do it don't try
that at home but after Queen takes G3
Ace takes G3 and then Bishop takes G3 is
mate beautiful mate here and here we are
with number four this is a Dutch defense
fools made pattern right so let's go to
this one and see what it looks like D4
and five right these F bonds some hey be
careful pushing your F Pawn okay just be
careful from either side now after D4 F5
Bishop G5 this is a cool move here
provoking some Pawn pushes so H6 attacks
the bishop the bishop has to move or
we'll just capture it so we back it up
but wait isn't the bishop just trapped
what is this G5 says black yo your
Bishop is trapped
when you move it to G3 I'm gonna play F4
and choppy winner and take your Bishop
but white has a clever move
that clever move is you know what hey
you can have the bishop E4 oh wow oh no
my Bishop I just hung my Bishop right
and then he takes the bishop and stares
at you but then you stare back at them
and play Queen H5 check mates game over
all right guys this one's number three
this is for my Scholars out there this
one's called Scholars mate all right so
here we go E4 E5
Bishop C4 get the bishop out you've
probably seen this one you might have
got hit with this one before and you
also can hit somebody with this same
Checkmate let's see it in action after
E4 E5 Bishop to C4 developed the piece
get the bishop out of the um outside of
the ball chain and we can also lock it
outside the pawn chain but we just want
to develop it in attack F7 after Bishop
C4 Knight to C6 defends upon it just
develops and we bring the queen now here
it is Moon Queen H5 very simple you can
go for this Checkmate all the time now
of course not recommended all the time
but definitely you need to know this
Checkmate after Queen to H5 is hitting
the F7 Square twice Knight to F6 what is
he going what are you do only Queen F7
and that's mate for all the scholars out
there keep up the great work here we are
with number two this one's called grop's
attack but it's definitely is not an
attack for white here after G4 is called
the ground this is a strange opening you
may have pasted before but it is
definitely strange here's a good move
from black here they go E5 hey just take
the center if you're gonna do crazy
stuff I'm just going to continue to take
the center white is continues to do
crazy stuff and play F4 here what on
Earth is this move we don't know but we
will play Checkmate when it's there we
need for our checkmates getting off the
board allowing a Fool's mate is what
they'll call this here but F4 and G4
pawns pushed we played E5 Queen H4 is
made on the Move that's number two here
we are with the last one of our top 10
fastest checkmates can you guess what
this one is we kind of hinted at it
before maybe you've known or seen this
one before this is like the fastest one
F3 right which some people do still play
F3 not the greatest opening it also
opens up the king but hey Black's just
saying hey whatever you can play
whatever you like I'm gonna play E5 I'm
gonna put a pawn in the center of the
board principles white says hmm you know
what F3 was nice let's try g42 as well
but that fails immediately I'm sure you
know what that is green H4 Checkmate
Falls mate on the board that's what they
call this one Fool's mate this is the
top 10 fastest checkmates hopefully you
guys enjoyed this one and if you enjoyed
this video then make sure you I see
other ones right after this we'll see
you on the next one